château margaux l'un des crues peut-être
le crû le plus prestigieux du bordelais
et cela depuis le 17e siècle peut être
considéré comme un patrimoine culturel
la société fiat par l'intermédiaire de
giovanni agnelli en posséder 75% à sa
mort récente cette part a été remise sur
le marché et c'est l'héritière des
magasins félix potin qu'il a racheté ce
fleuron de ce vignoble est donc redevenu
entièrement bleu blanc rouge eric perrin
vincent pacifique ans la première
impression est souvent la bonne château
margaux est un menu un monument
particulièrement goûté depuis quelques
jours à l'occasion des dégustation du
millésime 2002 omniprésente
corinne menzel au pool hausse depuis le
mois dernier cette femme d'affaires
classés parmi les 100 premières fortunes
françaises est l'unique propriétaire de
château margaux
autant le dire cette dégustation de crus
l'heure est pour elle un moment clé
c'est très important parce que ça permet
de voir la l'appréciation que les gens
se font de la qualité du millésime à
l'intérieur dû me dise in global de
situer leur appréciation de margaux le
prix et la vente de ce premier grand cru
classé dépend donc en grande partie de
la vie de ces négociants aux
journalistes spécialisés et pourtant
c'est toujours une sorte de privilège à
la limite parce qu une des propriétés
phare une marque d'exception dont le
monde finalement dans que pour nous
c'est presque un honneur de venir là
puis en réjouissement mons essonne punch
- c'est la référence etc si vous avez
les voitures la référence et ferrari
pour le vin c'est margaux château
margaux un terroir d'exception 90
hectares de vignes créée sous louis 15
un château 19e
les monuments historiques mais surtout
un nom à la réputation planétaire
février dernier la famille agnelli vent
les 75% du capital qu'elle détenait
l'important groupes financiers étrangers
sont sur les rangs mais c'est corinne
menegaux poulos déjà co actionnaire qui
l'emportent
montant de la transaction top secret
mais on parle à bordeaux de 350 millions
d'euros un record absolu
donc encore une de nos boulots et dans
le cas beaucoup de gens qui
s'investissent dans des très grands crus
la question du rendement ne se pose pas
pour priorité
étonnant certes mais d'un strict point
de vue économique un cru classé est en
fait d'une faible rentabilité
qu'importe l'histoire est ailleurs en
rachetant margot corinne menzel au
boulot c'est qu'elle marche dans les pas
de son père le fondateur du groupe félix
potin qui avait lui-même acquis la
propriété en 1977
posséder un grand cru c'est expérimenté
un rapport au temps à la quelqu'un va
pouvoir les goûters dans 25 ans dans 50
ans espère qu'ils auront une pensée émue
pour nos et de se dire que si ce qu'on a
fait là est aussi beau que ce que nos
prédécesseurs ont fait sur marveaux
souffre d'un fort mal
le millésime de nîmes s'échange
actuellement à plus de 600 euros la
bouteille et pourtant les amateurs
fortunés se l'arrachent château margaux
et bien un monument